April is with us in Florida hey April
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave
thank you so much for taking my call
Shirl job yeah so when I was 15 my dad
passed away and he left me with an
inheritance and his wishes were come
from my aunt to not give me the money
until I turned 25 well she gave me the
money when I was 18 and within a year
time the money had all disappeared and
how did the money disappear you blew it
um that's the thing I don't know there
she called my name how did you not know
I asked for an accounting I used the
money to pay for rent and to go to
school okay I wasn't done I stopped she
gave you the money
seven years earlier than your dad wanted
right
not in a lump sum yeah it was just
occasionally I like to hear here's a
here's a thousand dollars for rent
here's a thousand dollars for school I
thought you paid for a month but she
would commingle the money from my
account my inheritance account to her
account there was a time where she gave
herself give her a daughter alone and
told me that she paid it back for the
last ten years I've been asking her can
I have an accounting for my money and I
still haven't received one my question
is how can I go past her and get that
accounting how can I find out I can't
she's the only one that has the numbers
yeah she's the one that managed the
money and she's the only place together
she's the only source of information
okay so you think she stole it I mean I
don't want to say that but I don't know
why I haven't been provided in
accounting that's the only disorganized
in a ditz
I mean that's very possible
it's very possible you spent it all but
she didn't even manage to keep up with
it to know what the flip was going on
she probably was not a good person leave
in charge of this is she not is she a
role is she kind of impulsive and
flighty and this
organized are you very disorganized yes
so it's very possible she doesn't have
an accounting man is that right I mean
it's definitely possible yeah okay so do
you have any the records that you have
do you show receiving anywhere near
$100,000 no I mean the only thing that I
can maybe think of is maybe 60,000 so
you don't have an accounting of your
stuff either
no I mean I was 18 at the time not
obviously the best with money still not
the best with money and I I was given
the money I mean that was a lot of money
to be handed to me well she didn't hand
it to you she'd old it out yeah and now
it's all gone and I'm I have a family
now and I'm like wow that hundred
thousand dollars could really help me
right now
you spent 60 of it true at least you
might have spent 80 cuz you're not sure
you didn't do an accounting either you
were an adult you were making two adult
decisions with money you're responsible
for this
I don't think you have a right to blame
her for this she might have messed up I
doubt this lady's a crook
there might be ten or twenty thousand
dollars in play here but there's not a
hundred thousand dollars in play and she
didn't dump a hundred thousand on an 18
year old she'd old it out to you and you
don't have any idea what you did with it
or if you really got it or not because
you were so disorganized and flighty so
I'm sorry I don't think you're a victim
and I don't think she's evil I think
you're both disorganized and neither one
of you did a very good job of handling
your dad's money that he left to you and
that's sad but I don't think you can cop
the position that somehow she's she's a
CPA and she's got all these records in a
vault where she embezzled this money
from you that's just not even close to
what happened dear the way you laid it
out you know what I would sit down with
her over a cup of coffee and just say
hey let's try to put this together so I
can emotionally put this to bed in my
mind I'd like to know that I got all the
money but I don't know can you help me
with that please so I can put this
behind me but I really wouldn't sue her
over this because I don't think you got
a leg to stand on